Um, so I was able to, um, uh,
come to an intersection,
uh,
last week and I really enjoy
the discussion very much.
So I look forward to coming
to all the sections and just,
um,
you know,
managing the faces to the names and
just hearing your voice and your ideas.
So it was a, it was a great
experience last masters there. Um,
and um,
uh,
once again just can't stress enough how
important it is to take advantage of the
writing center. Um, so today
we're going to go back, uh,
and I just want to refresh your memory
about some of the things that we've been
seeing about for whom the bell tolls.
Um,
those kinds of seven permutation
that we're looking at. In fact,
pretty much all semester.
So individual entitled voluntary versus
involuntary foreign was just not foreign
literate or not literate.
Um,
and on Thursday we were talking about,
um,
the distant home versus
the onsite environment.
And it turns out that,
um, they really are,
are two very distant homes and maybe
just two homes for rather when there's
Paris, uh, which isn't really a real home,
but it is a home in the sand.
The stat is something that he can,
he has the luxury of taking
completely for granted. Um,
and um, so that's one definition of
home, the place where you can work.
Unselfconsciously.
Um,
and the other home is a
more complicated place, um,
in the sense that maybe it's not even
a geographical locale where the kind of
emotional shelter that is given to him,
um,
bestowed upon him and
really by his grandfathers,
very heroic, um, presence
in his civil war.
So it's 19th century home for him and he
needs that very much because of the non
home that is the 20th century.
Um,
I think that is really a
very sad fact about Robert.
And maybe it's true of some people,
you know,
sometimes it's true or some authors,
um,
that they really should have
that I've loved that, you know,
I feel that they really should
have existed in different
century and then things
would have been so much
easier for them. Um, rubber,
there's an exactly that kind of person,
but there is a sense that the
20th century has been very,
very hard on him and it's especially
hard on him because of the fact of his
father and really there's no more
central fact then what your parent was.
So this is the moment that
clears up a lot of things for us.
Why his own home is in some
sense a non home for him.
Um, so he got this gun by
that he, his pistol, uh,
there was his grandfather's
pissed off from the civil war, um,
that was misused by his own father.
And this is what Robert
does with that pistol.
He climbed out on a rock and leaned over
and saw his face in the Stillwater and
saw himself holding the gun and then he
dropped it, holding it by the muscle.
And so I'd go down making bubbles until
it was just as big as a watch charm in
that clear water.
And then it was out of sight.
This is the best that he can do for his
father is to make his father disappear.
The extent of the contamination that his
father has brought upon the memory of
his grandfather can be wash
clean only when he becomes,
um,
no more than the bubble.
And then now even the bubble
anymore in that clear water.
Um,
it clearly goes back to
Hemingway's conception of
clan in of how one clears out
one's life and in our time
and, uh, the big 200 river.
Um, but I think that it also, uh,
within for whom the bell tolls,
it also looks forward to the moment,
a traumatic moment,
uh,
when someone else is looking at something
like a mirror and seeing his own
reflection and they just want to call your
attention to the very, uh, deliberate,
uh, composition of this
particular visual. Tableau.
Robert isn't just dropping the gun.
He has to go up there.
He used to see his own face.
He has to see himself holding the gun.
And it's that kind of, um,
almost narcissistic, uh,
observation of himself that Hemingway
is really fascinated by and the
psychological meaning of that. So we
can read all kinds of meaning, um,
into this particular scene and we'll
see it repeated by another person, um,
in equally traumatic moment. But here, um,
it seems that Robert Really has no parent.
Um,
he looks at the world and the only thing
that he can see his himself is almost
as if he's really an often has always
been an often all the time, uh,
because his father is really
can really be a father to him.
And so the act of dropping the gun,
um,
is in some sense only a real description
of what has long been a psychological
fact for Robin. Um, so all of this, um,
highlights the fact of how
important it is to die.
Well not just for yourself,
but also for other people for whom you're
deaf would also be consequential in
here. The biography of Hemingway
really becomes quite important.
Hemingway's on father Doctor Clarence
Hemingway died by his own hand.
Um,
and we know that Hemingway himself
also died by his own hands.
So in many ways for whom that belt hose
is because of the meditation head of
time to that moment when Hemingway would
have to decide what to do with his own
life. Um, and so this was a front
page news in the New York Times,
June 3rd,
1961 front page news Chicago should be in,
um,
and on July,
but 1961,
the interpretation of the death of
Hemingway was that it was accidental.
There was cleaning his gun
and the gun just went off. Um,
and this fiction lasted for five
years until 1966 when his widow,
Mary Hemingway, finally admitted
that no, actually the heat,
it just put the gun into his own
mouth and blew out his own brains. Um,
so it took five years for
their truth to come out.
And now they're are all kinds of, um,
theory. And that just last summer, um,
I think it was July,
there was a lot of speculation that
Hemingway might have died because he was
under such close surveillance by the FBI.
Um,
so that's just a new theory that
would be still be coming up, uh, in,
uh, 2011, um, so many
years after the death, um,
people will still continue to have
conjectures about why it was bad Hemingway
killed himself. But I think that
once the WHO has been the Asian, um,
is that he was just in very, very poor
health and he was not able to write.
Um, and I think that for rather department
is nothing more painful than that.
Something that would make life more
meaningless than not being able to write.
So this is a picture of him,
uh, fairly close to the end.
And this was a public appearance,
so he wasn't looking too bad,
but we can sort of see that he really
wasn't looking well. And he was there.
It was a fishing competition in Castro.
Apparently one,
lots of trophies that Hemingway was
there to give him the trophies. Um,
but he really wasn't looking well.
So I think that that probably is the
simplest explanation that he no longer is
with he once was.
And he simply couldn't accept the fact
that there is this kind of a sharp
decline in, in, in, in his mental
abilities and physical abilities.
Um,
so this is the last image that I like
to show you of Hemingway is just we used
to write, um, and that is
the most important, uh,
place for him really in the
WHO. Well, um, and today, uh,
we'll talk about, um, thinking about
that, about how he ended his life.
We think about the varieties of dying,
um,
and then numerous ways by which people
and what's useful not to end the lives.
So Hemingway actually
covers the entire spectrum.
People who choose to die as well as
people who choose not to die, um,
and seeing what it means in each case.
So we'll begin by looking at,
um,
the central event in about hose,
the execution of the fascist.
Um,
and then we'll look at the
personal and or non and, uh,
various individuals beginning with the
neato whose name obviously is upon.
Um, and then the all women in the
Madrid market and then bombing,
which is a new phenomenon, um,
in the early 20th century. Um,
and then Robert's father again and
then Pablo, someone who refuses to die.
Um, but first of all, the
execution of the fascist. Um,
this,
we should remember this whole very
long episode is narrated by Palazzo.
Um, I hope that you guys will
talk about this in section,
what it means for a woman who's on the
Republican side to the recounting this
story, the execution of
her political enemies. Um,
and how she feels about us and why it is
the having chooses to have a woman tell
this story. So anyway, this is
[inaudible] speaking. Um, and how, um,
they are the, the gorillas, a
Republican gorillas have, um,
taken the town so they are going
to execute all the fascist.
And this is all engineered by Pablo.
He placed them in two lines as you would
place men for rope pulling contest or
as they stand in this city to watch the
ending of a bicycle road race with just
room for the cyclist to pass between or
as many as two to allow the passage of a
holy image in the procession.
Two meters was left between the lines
and they extended from the door of the
[inaudible] to mental clear across
the plaza to the edge of the cliff.
So that from the doorway of the unit
to Manto looking across the plaza,
one coming out with C,
two solid lines of people waiting for PLR.
This formation,
this particular visual tableau and was
against highly visual is emphasizing what
one would see coming out of
our unit to me until, um,
is two solid lines that
people vary all the way, um,
not inflamed by passion,
just doing what needs to be done.
And so all the metaphors
that Hemingway uses, um, uh,
actually rich ritualistic metaphors,
um,
something that is extremely well defined
were very well defined rules of the
game,
like rope pulling contests
or better yet a bicycle race.
Uh, not consider the violent
event, either of those,
um, or better, still more intensive.
Find a degree of ceremonious. Snus. Um,
is the procession with the whole
image of an icon going through.
So the three metaphors highlight the fact
that there is the equivalent of those
rituals,
a civic and religious rituals that would
be a political ritual of execution at
his most utopian,
the execution of your opponents,
which is a necessary thing.
In some cases,
the execution of your political
opponents should be as ritualistic as
ceremonious,
as free of passion as all
those other ritualistic events.
So this is very utopian moment in for
whom the bell tolls and if it could be
held at this level, then the
Spanish civil war willing to Calavo,
they in fact be a good
war or beautiful war.
And she tends to think of those terms.
And sometimes in alums we'll
talk about that. But in any case,
this is [inaudible] very
utopian description of what
a war could be and what you
could do to your enemies without
debasing them, without abusing them,
even though you do kill them.
Um,
and I try to find an image of the two
lines of people with the people who have
been executed passing of group. Um,
and I just couldn't find an image.
I guess it's not surprising new having
nobody will be taking pictures at that
moment. Um, but as it turns out,
one major art is actually
has numerous paintings. Um,
they seem to be alluding to that kind of
information. And is Robert Motherwell,
um, major 20th century artists.
And not only does he want,
he actually has numerous,
from the fifties to the seventies,
he produced numerous paintings all
call Lsu to the Spanish with her,
like with his two low inflammation.
So this is an early one that was
done in I think it was 1954. Um,
and this one is much later.
He numbers of them.
This one is in the Metropolitan
Museum. Um, and uh,
this one is one or two and I
don't remember what date it was,
but obviously later. Um, and this
one is quite late in the 70s,
um, one 10 now in the series
and is in the Guggenheim Museum.
So, uh, clearly, um,
Hemingway's talking about something
that is also recognized by other people.
Um, as in many ways the kind
of the Utopian moment, uh,
of the war when violence
is both a executed, uh,
but not allow to go to get out of hand.
But um,
having way also shows us that in
fact that that is not a sustainable,
you told here that that
violence kept within limits.
Violence kept within bonds,
um,
is not likely to last for the
whole duration of the war.
So,
um,
PLR refers to this as drunken
this coming into allies,
the people of this time
aura as kind as they are,
as they can be cruel and
they have a natural tendency,
they have natural sense of justice and
a desire to do that, which is right.
But cruelty had entered into the lines
and also in drunken is what the beginning
of drunkenness and the lines were not
as they were when Donald Benito had come
out in Spain.
Drunken is when reduced,
but other elements than wine.
It's a thing of great ugliness.
So already we're beginning to see the
language of beauty and ugliness coming
into the situation where it seems
that moral judgment is in play.
So polite is referring to real drunk
people who asked for people who are drunk
drunks in the,
in that episode.
But she was also referring to
another kind of drunk in is, um,
which is to be drawn with maybe
in the desire vendors, um,
drunk with your own
sense of momentary power,
absolute power over someone drunk.
Would you ability to bring about absolute
deep basement, um, in your opponent.
All those things can make
people in new created.
And so Hemingway is
really talking about him.
[inaudible] he's taught me about
different forms of inebriation, um,
and how they can all work to
break down this stability,
all otherness as their loneliest lists
of work. Really odd to be, you know,
more than the ritual. So, you know,
this is a breakdown of ritual that for
Pella marks the beginning of the chaos
and the modifier thems, um,
that takes over the scene. And,
um, so it just, because
we're talking so much about,
she just talks about early news.
Um,
and in many ways she's
inviting us to think about the,
both the ethics but also the
aesthetics and killing, um,
a book that is a person into that kind
of thinking is still scariest book on
beauty and being just in her argument is
that beauty is actually very important
consideration. Justice, um,
that the sense of proportion,
the sense of balance,
the sense of symmetry,
all those ideas that
we associate with you.
They should also be concepts that we
consider when we think about crime and
punishment, whether the punishment
is commensurate with the time.
So it's very interesting argument. Um,
and not really just about, you know,
not just about execution
of political prisoners,
but thinking about justice in general.
Um,
so just keep that in mind
as we go with a laugh. Um,
to talk more about the
breakdown of the line.
There's some drunken yeah.
Guillermo from the Lions imitating
the high cracked boys of his wife.
And Dawn Guillermo rushed to what the man,
the blindingly with tears now running
down his cheeks and the man hit him hard
and tries to phase,
which is Flowjo.
And Angelia Mo sat down from the force
of the blow and sat there crying,
but not from fear while they're drunk,
had speed and when drunk had jumped on
top of him Australia shoulders and beaten
with the bottle. Um, I,
my reading is not even doing justice to
just how horrendous the scene is. Um,
and I think that the reason that Hemingway
released singles out this moment,
um,
is in fact that incommensurability
between the punishment and the prime.
We know in fact and philosophy,
very careful to tell us that Guillermo
is not the worst or the fascist. In fact,
he is not rich. He doesn't own
anything he owns within those shop.
Um, he's, um,
he is a fascist because of
his wife because his wife
is religious and so he just
comes a fast as to humor
her. Um, so he really is,
is the last person who ought to be
executed under those circumstances.
And these also the last person who are
today in Malawi in this particular way,
um, this various kinds of execution that
doesn't have to be this kind of very
brutal, um, kind of, uh,
debasement of the person that
just very groovy mockery.
This is really one pillar means that
these people are naturally kind,
but they also capable of great crows.
Hey,
and this is the moment when we see
that crow to dramatize. So it's,
it's not even the killing of Guillermo
is the making fun of him. Um,
and um, and just the
whole treatise, the, Eh,
the scenario engineer,
um,
in such a way as to bring about the
maximum degradation on the part of glory,
Yam or this is what makes
this thing so unbearable.
And so for Pella, this is
the absolute vote point, um,
of the, of, of the whole, uh, maybe
over the whole Spanish that will,
up to that point. Although she
doesn't, she can look into infusion.
She doesn't know it's the
come, uh, but in any case, um,
this is the moment when all of a sudden
everything seems to be going the wrong
way and it is a turning
point for the worst for Hila.
I myself have felt much emotion
at the shooting of the Guardia,
so they'll buy Pablo polasse.
It was a thing of great ugliness,
but I had thought if
this is how it must be,
this is how it must be.
And at least there was no cruelty,
only the depriving of life,
which as we all have learned in this
year as is the thing of ugliness,
but also a necessity to do if we are
to win and to preserve the republic.
So it's a very complex bit of reasoning
here and it seems that a lot is actually
disagreeing with scary,
so scary things.
Then there's almost a kind of a perfect
match between Billy and justice, um,
that work. We, you know, mine's,
I not so much in the physical eye,
but in our minds eye in our mind.
Um,
what we recognize now Myers ISB beautiful
would also be just that there's that
kind of balance and symmetry but is making
a distinction between something that
is ugly and something that is morally
represent heritable and something that is
pooled. Are they calling necessary.
So those are the three clans,
concepts that are in play
in her head and for her,
something that is political,
politically necessary can also be ugly.
And Dennis,
okay,
so she can take ugliness.
She doesn't welcome, she doesn't
love it, but she can take it.
It is the quality as she can take.
Um,
and so based on bad distinction,
it is the fact that the
[inaudible] had entered the lines,
um, that cruise he had
enter into a vice for her.
That is the measure of just how much
the Spanish civil war has been corrupted
from within that
basically it has gone bad.
And that is a phrase that had been way
uses quite a bit as well in foamed about
hose Pablo is someone who has gone
bad and the Spanish civil war,
the Republican cause is
something that has gone back.
So the final reflection,
uh, from PLR bill,
I could not sleep that night.
And I got up and sat in a chair and
looked out the window and I could see the
square in the moonlight where the
lines had been and across the square,
the tuition money in the moonlight and
the darkness of the shadows and the
benches bright too in the
moonlight and the scandal bar,
those shining and beyond the edge of
the cliff where they had all been thrown
and there was no song, the splashing
of the water and the fountain.
And I sat there and I thought,
you have the gun badly.
So she's arriving at that work,
which for her is to Altoona where
the judgment, not ugly but bad,
um, that this is her
verdict on her own psi. Um,
so hello, of course is not
speaking for Hemingway. Um,
but I think that she has a lot
of authority. Um, and so, um,
somebody who pin is something that,
um, we should take very seriously,
um, at work. Um, those cruelty in any war,
you know, not just suspend this a whirl,
but first of all, war, second world war,
especially as a warm
up. I agree. Cruisy um,
at what point does cruelty
rented that side not justifiable,
and it actually isn't winning side,
maybe not justifiable. So, uh,
from there,
um,
from this kind of large scale
meditation on the Justice of war,
whether there could be a just
war or at what point, uh,
this ball was become unjust,
um,
from that Nasco macro, uh, meditation.
Um, let's move on now to
thinking about dying, um,
as a much more personal, uh,
phenomenon. Uh, and also, uh,
choice quite often.
Um,
having ways for interested in both
in people dying in voluntarily, uh,
but also in people.
Um,
choosing to live on voluntarily even
though living on might not be a very
beautiful thing, uh, might not
even be actually an ethical thing.
Whether that is a kind of a
funny thing to say. Uh, but, um,
the,
he's only seems to be really thinking
about looking forward to his own and all
this, uh, episodes, but beginning
with the ball, Fido, uh,
finito so this is someone who is already,
um,
his career is over at this
point. He's gone. His last car,
the last bull fight, and
this is the ceremony, uh,
celebrating the end of his career and
his retirement and his glorious career.
Up to this point,
finito did not eat much because here we
see if Apollo taxo a blow from the flat
of the Horn when he had gone in to kill
in this last corridor of the year is our
hoser.
So the president of the club,
which at the end of the speech
and then everybody cheering him,
he stood on a chair and
reached up and anti the court,
the bound purple shroud over the head
and the head of the ball was as though he
were alive,
his far,
it was curly as Enlive and his nostrils
were open and his eyes were bright and
he was there looking straight as finito.
Everyone shouted and applauded and
Finito some further back in the chair in.
And everyone was quiet and
looking at him and he said, oh no,
and looking at the ball and pull
further back. And then he said, no,
very loudly and if big blob of blood
came out and he didn't even put up the
Napkin and a slit down his chin
and he was still looking at a goal.
There's a lot of looking in Hemingway,
we can write up,
you guys can write a great paper just
by looking at the dynamics of looking,
the, the soothing, the gaze
that we cast upon someone else.
And sometimes the gaze that
they cast back at us. Um,
quite often there's a kind of a
reciprocal process and here it is indeed a
reciprocal process for NATO is looking
at the ball and the ball is looking at
him. Um, even though was a dead,
it doesn't matter that boom walk and look
back at Youtube and it seems that here
Ashley, um, it is not with the Ido.
This thing is not a mirror image.
And that's what's so
heartbreaking about it.
It would have been great if it had been
a mirror image because what he sees in a
ball, it's actually a board
and a full vigor of life.
This ball, even though it's dead, um,
he's more alive than when he
was alive, it seems, um, his,
for his curly hair, um, his nostrils
are open, his eyes are bright.
He's just a great spectacle. Um,
and more than that, his element,
he seems to be in doubt
with live even after death.
And so if this were a mirror image,
this ought to have been through needle
in his prime with life when he was a
great the door when he
wouldn't be coughing glove,
when he will be able to eat instead of
now and he can eat anything because of
the damage that's been done to this.
So if this were a mirror image,
vanilla would have been young again.
But we all know that
that's not going to happen.
And so Hemingway is clearly
punning on the worth and you know,
this is a man who was finished when the
man is finished in this particular way.
Um,
is it better or worse for him to be
still alive when it have been better?
If he had been killed earlier,
just like the ball,
then he would have been preserved
and at the maximum height,
high point of his life.
So I mean I think that is not the kind
of thinking that actually we want to
intelligent all the
time. Um, but it is, um,
something that I think that Hemingway
has to, it takes very serious seriously,
obviously.
Um,
and so for him this was a kind of a
comic tragic comic moment of survival.
Yes.
I mean Nathan Ito is hanging on there.
He's not about to this fashion itself
voluntarily. It's going to hang on. Um,
but it's a very dubious
kind of hanging on.
And the only redeeming thing that we
can say about it is that it's funny.
It's conical. So once again, the
only way that we can take this,
we can swallow their stomach. It is
by saying it is a comical moment. Um,
and for whom and about hose.
And there's another equally tragic comic,
I would say mostly comic moment,
um, in formed about those,
about something hanging on with using
the die even though they had finished as
Finito is awesome finish.
Um,
this is PLR talking to um,
to uh,
Robin about some old about the smell of
death and then he doesn't know what that
smells like and she tells him to go to
the market and you must go down the hill
imagery to the planting the two lado
early in the morning to method era and
stand there on the web paving where
there's a fog for the mercenaries and wait
for the old women who go before they
like to drink the blood of the bees that
are slaughter.
When such an old woman comes out of the
two Darrow holding her shawl around her
with her face,
gray and an eyes hollow and the whiskers
of age on a Chin and on her cheeks sat
in a Wetson wider foo phase as the
Sprouse grow from the seed of the bean,
not bristles, but pails, routes,
sprouts in a death of a phase.
Put your arms ties around her English
and holder to you and kiss her on the
mouth.
And you will know the second part,
that voter isn't made up.
Um,
I definitely think this is in this quite
a bit of he ain't going on. I mean,
you know, oh, people, male and
female kind of look bad. Um,
but Hemingway seems completely fixated.
Um,
how bad or women look.
and especially the bean
sprouts growing on the face.
Um, it's sort of, you know,
and I think that that's why it sort of
comic and it's okay because of that,
um, that, um,
that actually lots of very well known
all the women have this kind of whiskers
on the phases. Um, and it's,
you know, it's just a fact.
And,
but for Hemingway it seems to be kind
of a reproach on the go women that they
should have this rove
on, on the faces, um,
and that in many ways, um,
are going against nature.
Then suddenly they have come men rather
than women who have whiskers on the
phases and so on. Um, and so they
really ought to have died earlier. Um,
instead of allowing this unnatural
phenomenon to happen to them. Um, I mean,
it's, it's, it's, it's, it's really
very small incident, but nonetheless,
the count of female counterpart
to the Finito story.
Um,
and it just wanted to stop here for a
moment and talk a little bit about in the
connections between Hemingway and Fisher,
because in fact,
used seeing this phenomenon before,
uh,
of a kind of unnatural grove that
is almost a parody of nature.
So we've just had this tragic,
um,
calming being Sprouse on a human face.
And,
um, actually in Fitzgerald, uh,
we have a kind of non comic version of
that in the great Gatsby in the Valley of
the ashes with the ashes growing.
Like we've now you the
passage of the moment. Um,
but Hemingway also has the kind of non
comic hello to the Fitzgerald version,
which is also kind of the preparer
they have nation that we'll look at.
But first,
um,
something that is almost like the Marcus
thing of the bean sprouts in the great
gas Gatsby.
This is a valley of ashes,
a fantastic farm where ashes grow like
wheat into ridges and hills and quote has
gotten right.
So if his Gerald's was talking about
some kind of grotesque vegetation that is
made up of the animate and inanimate.
And in many ways Hemingway is talking
about exactly the same thing that bean
sprouts. Um, the women
are almost inanimate.
They really ought to be in that mood is
a, uh, is a caricature of the animal.
They are animate.
Um,
but in any case it is the two will
couldn't mingling of the elements and the
inanimate they he's talking about and
that Fitzgerald is also talking about.
So I'm just really curious
that the organic inorganic
mixed in this way for both
authors, um, for, I would say
that for, for Fitzgerald is, is,
is very hard to see this as comic
and all on me didn't try very hard,
but this is just not that funny is,
is um,
is dominance is, was to a tragedy. Um,
but Hemingway also has,
um,
a completely non comic,
uh,
parallel to that of something
that is almost a parody of nature.
Except that it doesn't take the form
of bean sprouts in is a human invention
that looks like the work of nature.
That's something else.
So this is about the bombing of the
El Sordo band on the top of the hill.
They'd been a chase to the top of the
hill and they basically kept their bio
firing power the enemy,
and they on the top of the hill.
So there being just being bombed,
the maximum,
one of the efficiency for the bonds.
Then through the hemorrhaging of the gun,
there was the whistle of
the air splitting of the,
and then the red black roar to Irv rode
under his knees and then waste up to hit
him in the face and then do it and bits
of rock with falling all over and the
nausea was lying on him and
the gun was lying on him.
But he was not bad because the whistle
came again and to go of wrote on the him
with the roar.
Then they came again and earth lodge
under his valley and one side of the
hilltop grows into the air and fell
slowly over them. Why did they,
supposedly it is bombs dropped by
all those bombers that we saw, right?
The Hind Co's and the fear
that's the German hung clothes,
Italian and dropping the
bombs. Um, in this case,
I think there's just the Italian bombers.
Um,
but the way that this moment of bombing
is described three times in this passage
is that to earth is wising up and
hitting the gorilla band who are,
uh, everyone from miss
killed in this bombing. Um,
it is the fact that the earth seems
to be conspiring with the bombers and
hitting the human beings that
it has nurtured artist's time.
That is the outlet in so, and
as the ultimate injury, um,
that the Spanish Patterson's,
they live on the Earth Day thing that
earth is on their side and to have the
earth suddenly joining
the side of the enemy.
It's about the worst thing
that could happen. Um,
and so this is the cruelty of
the description of that study.
Included is very much coming
from Hemingway himself.
He didn't have to describe the
bombing as the action of the earth,
the earth rising up and
hitting all these human being.
He doesn't have to
describe them in his way.
He's describing the incident in this way
deliberately to highlight the fact that
in which nature has been
perverted by human action,
the modern technology has proved really
nature so that nature is no longer a
place where human beings can be
[inaudible] is that nature is something of
itself, is a weapon that can
be used against human beings.
Um,
and what is also true
about this particular who
realignment of the Earth with
the anime is that it reaches back and
retrospectively and retro actively we rice
and ionizers and earlier moment because
this is not the first time that we hear
about earth rolling or moving up.
In fact,
one of their most famous
little detail from, um,
the phone about houses that
when you have good stats,
supposedly the earth move under your,
um,
and this is what Pella wants to get the
information that allows us to get from
Maria to make sure that, um, that
everything is fine. Um, that this,
that this in fact happened over move.
Maria said, not looking at a woman,
truly it was a thing I cannot
tell the for you in glaze.
The law looked at Robert
Jordan. Don't lie. Yes,
he said truly good.
[inaudible] good.
That's downtime.
So this is back in page one 74,
um,
the earth moving,
it's all on the human side.
And for someone who is a very short life,
everyone seems to know that Robin Meyers,
we have a very short life.
For someone who's going
to have a furniture life,
having that experience is very important.
So on one 74,
[inaudible] 74,
um,
the earth moving has one connotation
and the cruelty of what happens on page
three 21 is that it completely,
we rice that earlier scene and the
size of a completely different,
in fact the opposite meaning to the movie.
So this is worth having ways of,
that's quite brutal narrative,
um,
can do is that even something
that seems to be safely concluded,
um, you know, that earth moving for, um,
Robert and uh,
Maria,
even though that is safely
conclude it in the past,
it is actually not safe from a
subsequent where you're writing and a
reassignment of meaning. Um, so, um, that,
that the meaning of the earth
moving clearly is in flux. Maybe,
uh, maybe it's, it could be
either way or maybe later event.
Ashley can completely erased early.
Meaning I think we have to decide
for ourselves to what extent page,
truthfully one can undo that
earlier, uh, Utopian moment,
uh,
but want to talk about now talk about
two other things that are associated with
dying and not dying.
Um,
both hinting on the work
called body Howard. Um,
the first actually goes
back to Robert's father. Um,
and for a long time, I
mean, not for a long time,
but when we're looking at the sea
with is just dropping the pistol, um,
in the, in the water, um,
this node scription of how he
feels about his father. Right?
It's just that he wants
to get rid of the gun.
He never wants to see the gun again.
That's it.
It's managed to get rid of the gun.
Um, but actually there is, um, uh,
upfront description of how Robert
feels about his father and also a
clarification of what he
needs his grandfather, uh,
how I wish grandfather are hell,
I wish my father was here.
He thought for about an hour anyway,
maybe he said the low I have through
the other one that misused the gun.
Maybe that is a bit lonely, the
communication that we have, but damn it,
I'll never forget how sick it made.
The first time I knew he was a cold body.
Go on.
Say it in English.
Coward is easier when you have a set and
there's never any point in referring to
a son of a bitch by some foreign term.
He wasn't in his son of a bitch though
he was just a coward and that was the
worst luck. And then, um, it's actually,
if it is interesting for multiple reasons,
um,
one is that, um, Robert really hosted,
he's the grandson of his grandfather.
Rather than the son of his father.
And that's really clear. And because
both at the, uh, describe him,
he has both his grandfathers
when's on and his father's son, um,
if he had the choice in
much rather be the phone.
So he's certainly hoping for the basket,
which is that his father
would just disappear and that
one link will be invalid,
would be an invalid like,
um,
but the way that he thinks
about his father, um,
is first of all that this is a moment
when Spanish tends to come in handy.
That maybe it's easy just to ease your
way into that way you're thinking about
your father.
So you go by way of a foreign language,
but then you really have to say
it in your, in your own town. Um,
but then the way that he thinks
about that where there's actually,
um,
two f emptied of any moral judgment,
I think they will use the word coward.
We'd had to attach a lot of moral
significance to that term, right?
It lack of bravery, um, is a kind
of moral failing or the polio,
the person, um, who you know,
who is lacking in that quality.
Um,
but finally Robert is just emptying
that have that moral judgment and the
saying,
there's some people were just unlucky.
Some people would just born not
very brave and it's not up to them.
If they are born author engrave it is
too much to expect absolute bravery from
them. They just, they're
not meant to be brave.
And when they try it on a certain thing
is when they can meet that test of
bravery, then they go into break. Um,
so this is his way of accounting for
the fact that his father can live on
stubbornly, um, doesn't have the
will to live, to keep them going.
Just to make sense of
that in his own mind.
So in this incident, um,
how was the decision to die?
Is rendered acceptable?
Is not still not a great thing,
but he can wrap his mind around it.
And that's really one who wants to do,
is to be able to wrap his mind around
the fact of his father's suicide.
Um, but I think that
Hemingway actually, um,
and this really speaks to how far he is
able to imagine a position that in the
end we know that will be
the opposite of his own.
How far is able to imagine,
um,
and give all dignity, uh, or
maybe a kind of emigration,
um,
to someone's decision not to die.
The stubborn decided to
hang on and not just to be,
not just to go right now.
Um,
and so parallel to that's the
method symmetrical to this,
but also antithetical to
his father's action, um,
is the cold bothers will to survive.
Um,
and the person who embodies
that will to survive is Pablo,
who might argue is actually one of
the most interesting characters,
arguably more interesting than
Robert, um, in this novel. Um,
because he's,
he's so much goes on inside his head and
also through him that we actually don't
see represented represented in the novel.
So this is one area where Hemingway even
versus the fact that this
is some information not
getting and that information,
that lack of information or that
nondisclosure of information.
Ashley Mix a problem with the fair
and steal his person that he is.
Anyway,
Pablo is close to being killed at Esmo.
One [inaudible] hit him again,
hot in the mouth and Harlow laughed at
and showing the Yellow Bat broken chief
in the red line and the smell
of leave it alone. Pablo said,
and rich the cup to scoop
some wide from the boat.
Nobody here has Kohona is to
kill me and this head is silly.
Khobar the Augustan said no,
no words either.
Pablo said and made a swishing noise.
Rinsing the one in his mouth.
He spat on the floor.
I'm fat,
I'm far pass was Goossens stood there
looking down at him and cursed and
speaking slowly,
clearly,
physically and contemptuous late and
cursing as steadily as though he were
dumping the newer on their field,
lifting it with a Dung for our wedding
and Dow and doubt against turn from a
door and spoke to him putting
all his contempt into this thing.
Go to yes,
me set Pablo.
I will lead a life when you are dead.
So Augustan is trying his best to get
into a fight so he could do killed right
then and there.
And Pablo is doing everything he can
to stay alive and he's succeeded.
So no question about
it is an absolute how.
And you know he's going to be stand there
and bacon salad maybe for as long as
as boosting his breath and south
and he's not going to be great.